"Super Easy"
Just like your mother!
*Crickets and puking in the distance*
Oh goddammit.
"Best Player in the World" huh? That's setting pretty high
expectations for myself.
*determined battle cry*
Ohh ow...
Wha..? Oh- OH GOD!!
I wasn't r- AH!
My head! It barely poked t- oh...
*chuckling* Hey... how's it going there?
Oh god!!
L- oh fuck, right up my nose! Ah shit.
Well. Ow.
Oh...hAAAHA! Oh fuck me then!
WHOOOOOOOOOOOOA
FAAAHAAAA
WOAAHAAA
Aw shit, goddammit.
(in slight gibberish) I'M GONNA DIE.
*high pitched screams*
AAAHH MY BUTT.
*still high screaming*
*pleased laughter*
It doesn't feel like I win when I explode.
"Sword Cliff Fight"
Whoa!
You wanna go, bruh?
*epic battle cry*
Uh oh.
*defeated battle cry*
Oh god, I thought I got you!
*laughing* I thought I got you!
Eh, let's try this again.
Oh yes, good honorable fight we have!
*defeated battle cry x2*
Awwww shiiiiiiit duuuuude.
Sword in the stone! I'm King Arthur, bitch!
Ohoh fuck! *defeated battle cry x3*
(low murmuring) Gonna be- this is gonna be the one.
*epic battle cry x2*
AH FU-
THIS TIME IS GOING TO BE VICTORIOUS.
(high pitched) FUCK YOU
MAYBE IF I JUST FLAIL WILDLY.
*semi-victorious battle cry*
I got you on the grundle even though you got me on mah bunnssss!
Jus-who's gonna let go first?
Huh?!
OH YEAH! THAT'S RIGHT!
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FOR TRYIN' TO MESS WITH MARKIMOO! *triumphant chuckle*
Oh no. He's secretly a Nazi!
STOP SWASTIKA-ING!
Shit. *defeated battle cry x4*
OH, WHYYYYYY?!
*laughing* HE GOT REVENGE!
I count that as a wiiin!
"Destroy the City 2."
Well I don't know why that needs to happen.
Why can't I make peace with the lovely city?
Oh I'm so sorry.
Well you little lovely stick people.
Oh that was a classroom!
*laughing* Tha- that was students...
Oh god, nooooo.
The Fútbol [soccer] ball stadium.
I don't know what that is.
Ah shit.
*laughter*
"Small Wizard with HUGE atta-" well shit.
*short scream*
Ohhhh, not gonna get me!
WOOooo not gonna get me!
Ohhhhh shit!
I'm way too good for you guys.
Like a- *frighten/surprised Markimoo scream*
Oh ho ho ho ho...
Oh get off of me!
(kinda high pitched) AAAAAAHHHH GET OUT THE WAY!
I need to win! Thank you! Bye into oblivion!
Uh huh.
How about- WOOOO...
*surprised high pitched screams*
(high pitched) NOOOOO!!!
Shit. I thought it was going to be this stupidness.
Oh.
Well I didn't do it. Don't complain to me.
Is dat a coin?
I dunno is it?
*high pitched scream of death*
*chuckling* Oh shiiit
Alright let's try this again.
Except we WON'T be trolled.
AAAH
(panicked high pitched) AAAHH NOOOOOOO!
Oh shit I didn't- wait- AH!
Oh my spiiiine.
Let go please!
I'm- OOOOOOKAAAAAY?
I think I won?
Uh let's try this again. I think- I don't think I won properly.
(kinda high pitched) Aaaah...
Ah shit.
Oh- wel- oh- oh- oh fuck
*cautious scream*
Oh ho!
Ah ha!
Oh god!
If this was real,
I'd be so screwed.
Aaah don't kill me!
Don't kill me!
(kinda high pitched) AAAAHHH...
Okay we're fine!
Alright everything's fine-
(kinda high pitched) OH NO!
Okay, "go slowly."
I- AAH
Oh ho ho ho, fuck-
AH! Oh god!
Stop it!
AAAHH ha ha!
Oh ho ho fuck off dude!
Ahhhh it's so much baaaad!
Euuuuuug- *scream*
*chuckling* Okay it's fine. Everything's fine!
Everything's 100%- whoOOO!
I'm sorry man!
Oh boy.
Am I supposed to go forward  or... aaaahh shit.
Okay. Everything's fine.
*chuckling* Okay. YAAAAY!!!
Somehow we did it!
Yeah!
Alright "Epic Freeze."
Into the "freeze zone!"
In- into the- INTO TH- INTO THE FUCKING FREEZE ZONE!!
*panicked scream*
*sigh of relief*
*another sigh of relief*
*chuckling*
"Freeze Fall."
Shit this isn't what I was looking for.
Ah ga- ahhhh fuck.
Without my arms, how will I?
Oh just like this apparently.
Ahhh shiiit.
Goddammit.
Fuck this.
In the ass!
AAAHHH.
(high pitched) NOOOO!
(still high pitched) OH GOD!
How could anybody?
How could anybody?!
Maybe if just the vestige of my arm gets through I'll be able to succeed.
Probably not though.
Can't grab shit.
Very, very impossible.
HABOOSKI!
HO! (slight lisping) SHITHTH...
Hooo.... goddam-ow...
(sing songy) Haaaahhh-BOOSKI!
Fuck yooou!
Oh shit.
I'm- OH HO Ho ho ho fuuuu...-
HA HA HA HA- OH HO HO HO HO-
AH WHOA EH WHOA EH WHOA HA HA FACEPLANT ON TO THE VICTORY ZONE!
Habada- ohhhhhhh!
OHHHHHHHH! OHHHHHHHHH!
HOO HOO HOO HOO! HA HA HA HA!
HO HO HO HO!
*laughing*
Where you gonna go? Huh? You catching up to me? Not quite!
Hep!... aw shit.
YAAAAY-HAY !
*panicked gibberish*
OH GOD.
NO!
(panicked old man voice) I'M TOO OL- YOUNG! I DON'T WANNA DIE!
NOT MY BALLS!
NOT MY BALLS!!
*high pitched scream*
*pained sigh*
If I just...
Wait it out- huah!
Shit. That-
H- YEAH! HA HA HA HA HA! I WIN!
"A funny map."
It said it was a funny map but I'll be the judge of- wow, okay well...
Some 'Inception' level shit going on here.
I dunno what good this is gonna do me.
But okay.
What if I...?
HABOOTHH!
HA HA! I DON'T KNOW WHY THAT WON!
"Largest-" Whoaaa. Wha- "Leaderboard?" AH I'M NOT READY.
AAAAAAAHHHH WHOOOOO!
Uhhh...
Ohhh
OHHHHHH...
OHHHHHHHHHHH
OHHHHHHHHHHHH
OHHHHHHHHH
DO I LET GO?!
*uncertain high pitched scream*
I shouldn't've let go.
Ohhh let g- OH MY GOD
Okay then.
YEEEAAAAAAAH WHOOOOOHOOHOOHOOOO!!
Do I let go?
Ooookay let go.
Um...
I'm putting a lot of fai- WHOAAAAHAHA. I'm still dead!
Who're you?!
"Sword Fight Volcano."
OH GOD.
*surprised high pitched scream*
I WASN'T READY!
I WAS TOO DISTRACTED!
STOP GRABBING ONTO MY DICK!
WITH YOUR SWORD!
I'M ALREADY DEAD...
Ah shit dude.
*epic battle cry x3*
*victorious laugh*
Killed you with your own sword!
"Stickman Pogo Fight."
I dunno how we're gonna fight.
But okay.
HAB- *blows raspberry*
That's what you get.
HOH!
Ho ho! Knvies mean nothing to me!
Oh shit.
He is a maniac.
OH.
Fuck- OW!
*"knife up the butt ain't stopping me" chortle*
*high pitched "sudden death" screaming*
(high pitched) WHAT THE FUCK?!
So far, so good.
HA!
Whoa ho ho!
You shot your bow!
*imitates stickman screaming*
Oh ho, geez the scream scared me more than anything.
He-ah. "Freezer?"
What do you mean?
HABOOSKI!
Do it.
Nah you didn't do nothin'.
Uh oh.
"Boss" incoming.
Oh I hope it's gonna be someone good!
Or bad!
Or someone I can beat appropriate- OHHH!
*high pitched ball crushing scream*
YOUR BALLS!
Who knew he was gonna throw his balls at me?! I didn't know!
I'm just preemptively bouncing so I don't get blasted away by no...
big ol' balls!
Some "ball-tastic" testicl- oh...
BaHAHAHOO! *"successful ball jump" laugh*
Miss me!
(mockingly) Ha ha ha HA ha! You fell over! What a douche-nozzle.
I'll just go over here. "Archer Alert?"
Well that doesn't sound good. Why are there gonna be more archers...
after... the boss?
Uh... do I need to worry about that?
Probabl-bl- oh heeeey yeah just fall over and get up.
Ahhhh shit.
*'Crazy La Paint' outro begins*
EhhhhhHHHHH FUCK YOU! Man these guys need to learn to hold on to their bows.
Ahhhhh! Okay so far, so good!
Who the hell are you?!
You better not be...
BLOCKING OFF MY PATH BRUH!
Get outta here!
Yeeeeah!
(voice-over Markiplier) This has been "Happy Wheels Highlights." Thanks for watching!
If you wanna see more "Happy Wheels" right now, check the description or click the annotation for the full
"Happy Wheels" playlist.
And if you wanna see more "Happy Wheels" in the future, please click the "like button" to let me know!
Thanks again everyone!
And as always, I will see you... in the next video!
BYE BYE!
Also pizza